russian-backed separatists in several
ukrainian regions have announced
referendums on joining russia the
self-proclaimed luansk and donetsk
people's republics in eastern ukraine as
well as hassan in the country's south
will begin voting friday on officially
joining the russian federation
the decision comes as kiev continues its
counter-offensive in eastern and
southern ukraine
joining us now from
northeastern ukraine is our
correspondent nick connolly nick tell us
more about what's just been announced
so far the details are pretty scarce ben
but this is something that was expected
there's been talk of this for months and
various dates were announced and then
shelved as ukraine's advance pushed
those russian troops forward now it
seems like they're in a big big hurry
there's i think very little doubt as to
what those results will look like and
then the next step being russia to
accept that entry into the russian
federation we've heard top figures in
moscow talk about accepting that request
in kind of uh you know extraordinary
speed i think the interesting thing to
look at is that russia has played a game
since 2014 using these kind of entities
in donetsk and lhansk pretending that
they are independent even though their
leaders have russian passports are often
members of the ruling party in russia
and now i think i guess that the kind of
usefulness of this game has been lost
russia is you know in ukraine with the
russian army and so now in a situation
where ukraine is really doing quite well
the battlefield pushing russia back at
faster speeds anyone could have expected
they're basically giving up on this
pretense and uh you know looking to
incorporate these territories into
russia at least that's what their their
line will be in their interpretation
the vote has been rumored for months uh
now this sudden need
for speed uh
what sort of success uh
uh or basis do you think there will be
in this vote
i mean i think that the result is kind
of pre uh
pre-arranged i think we know that
there's very little chance of anything
but a huge majority for during russia i
think the reason why this is happening
now is partly internal it's because
russia is having huge difficulties
recruiting enough people to fight and if
the russian authorities can claim at
least internally that this is about
ukraine attacking russian territory at
least territory that russia claims
russian territory then it can mobilize
it can force people to fight to
previously be able to get out of
fighting
it's also about trying to kind of bank
some territory and situation where it
looks to be losing ground here in
ukraine showing russian domestic kind of
viewers what this is all about what the
point of this war has been but also more
internationally it's about having the
opportunity to threaten ukraine with the
use potentially of nuclear weapons to
say this is russian territory if you're
going to attack us here then we will use
everything we've got to defend our own
territory now i don't think anyone
outside russia is going to go anywhere
near this and recognise this but that
certainly is the kind of brinkmanship
that seems to be coming into this russia
seemingly convinced that the outside
world especially europe is not willing
to escalate further that it has the kind
of greater tolerance the greater
willingness to go big and to kind of up
the stakes here and hope that somehow
these kind of announcements uh force the
eu european backers and american backers
of ukraine to come back to the table to
negotiating table and maybe call some
kind of truce
how are ukrainian authorities likely to
respond
i think they're going to ignore it we've
seen how the ukraine's army has been
targeting russian military installations
in crimea another part of ukraine that
russia claims is its own territory has
claimed as russian since 2014 and we've
seen consistently announcements from the
us that they
continue to see
crimea as ukraine as such the ban on
using u.s made weapons against russian
territory doesn't apply to crimea it
won't apply to and the hands can so
basically ukraine will continue its
military offensives maybe even trying to
speed things up a bit to get in the way
of this kind of creeping russian
takeover in donetsk and hans
nick connolly for us in hakib thank you
and for an overview of the fast-moving
situation on the ground here's dw
reporter joel dalroy
in a matter of days ukrainian troops
have managed to roll back months worth
of russian gains and although they have
slowed a little they are not stopping as
they push further east well here's a
look at how the military map has changed
at the start of the summer in june
russian forces were in charge of almost
all of the territory from hakeev in the
north to herson in the south but in
early september ukraine launched its
surprise counter-offensive operation in
kharkiv and this is the result they
reclaimed almost all of the hakiv region
there in the north reaching the russian
border and on monday they announced that
they had crossed the oskil river now
that puts ukrainian troops on the
doorstep of neighboring lukansk region
now that is an area that moscow named as
one of its intended targets of its
invasion and ukrainian units are now
moving towards several strategic cities
that they lost to russian troops just
months ago
but these new territorial gains they
come with grisly discoveries near the
city of israel officials are uncovering
a mass grave they estimate over 400
civilians and soldiers were buried there
in recent months some appearing to have
been tortured and it is the second such
mass grave uncovered following russian
occupation the first was near butcher
near kiev where more than 450 bodies
were found
and there are also fears of what might
be found in mariupol in the south that
is still under russian occupation
satellite images appear to show mass
burial sites there too
well russia denies it has carried out
any atrocities or war crimes inspectors
from the united nations are heading to
israel to reach their own conclusions
so as ukrainian troops hope to take more
towns from russia there are fears of
what they may find when they arrive